all right now remember we also said that
no matter where this is they only point
if I took the point over here or down
here or something like that okay
according to this definition every point
is the same distance from the origin do
you agree so this distance here and this
one here and now on they're all the same
okay now just for the sake of
illustration I'm just going to say let's
make the radius of the circle a nice
easy number like two three okay now I
know that the distance from the origin
the center to this point on the
circumference wherever it happens to be
I know that that distance is three
because it should be three everywhere
that's what this means okay all right
pick up your pen don't roll this diagram
yet if you have it already I want you to
draw when I'm about to put on the
left-hand side okay we know what the
distance between two points is all the
way back in coordinate geometry we spent
quite a lot of time using a formula for
the distance between two points I'll
give you a clue it has a big square root
side in it does anyone remember it
okay now it's been a little while since
we've seen this so maybe you don't
remember I hope it jogged your memory
where you see it but here's the really
cool bit right color I can use that to
help me understand this watch carefully
okay on this circle I know that all of
these distances here they're all equal
to 3 right they're all over 2 so I'm
going to say instead of distance I'm
going to say 3 right because I know that
distance is always going to equal to
that number
now that's equal to now what's going to
go on our right-hand side well our x1 y1
that's just a pair of coordinates right
some point and x2 y2 they're just the
corners of some other point does that
make sense but look I but I've got two
points here I've got two points here so
Mike one is going to look something like
this let's make let's make this one the
first point and this one the second
point okay
so x1 minus x2 is going to be X minus 0
right X minus 0 and that has been
squared ok then when I go over to this
part of the equation I'm looking at the
Y values
well this Y value is just called Y and
this Y value is 0 so this part will be Y
minus 0 squared ok I could simplify this
a lot the first thing I'm going to do is
I actually don't like the square root
sign it's a pain to draw every time it's
huge so I'm going to square both sides
instead I can't go to square both sides
I'm going to say 9 over here and over on
the right hand side in a minute I don't
have to write the square root sign
anymore because I squared it ok X minus
0 that's just equal to X so that guy is
x squared Y minus 0 is just Y
so this part is y squared now this thing
here to start we've done we've turned
all these words which are kind of nice
we sort of know what they mean but we've
turned them into this equation that
we've had for every other kind of graph
but it's a weird equation right it's
different to everything you've ever seen
before
all four of the graphs I showed you
earlier are y equals this y equals that
etc Y is the subject this guy is
different and weird but cool junk rush
Ramone great question from this line to
this line I did two things which
admittedly I try to avoid doing but
they're fairly simple and I can try to
explain them over here what happened all
the brackets why are they all disappear
because because X minus 0 is just X and
y minus 0 is just Y so you know what's
happening over there but then I didn't
want to write the square root sign
either because it's just a pain okay so
what I did to both sides was I squared
both sides that term 3 & 2 9 on the
right hand side that tend to square it
into not a square root anymore so this
guy this guy is the equation of a circle
but it's not just any circle it's it's
this circle it has the center at the
origin 0 0 and it has a radius all right
okay so therefore if we played out this
experiment again and I said I want a
bigger circle I don't want a radius of 3
I'd like a radius to say 7 a lot of this
would play out the same what is it the
origin will still be the center so
everything on the right hand side would
look the same the left hand side would
be a teeny bit different it wouldn't be
9 it would be 49 because there'd be a 7
here because that's what you want the
radius to be and then you square it so
you get 49 instead of 7 ok if you wanted
the radius to be 10 then this final
number will be
100 if you wanted the radius to be
whatever this is whatever squared okay
so underneath here you can say I'm going
to switch those x squared plus y squared
equals R squared this is the equation of
any circle centered at the origin okay
so you can see this x squared plus y
squared stuff it comes from this
distance formula comes from Pythagoras
actually and the R squared what happened
because I didn't want to write the big
square root everywhere because that was
a bit of a pain